it's not quite a white horse but today a
night in his white Rolls is turning up
to do his bit for the NHS
[Music]
tremendous amount of his word sir Rod
Stewart is at his local hospital in
Harlow Essex to fulfill a pledge he made
live on Sky News
we have a caller now who's been
compelled to call us this afternoon
after watching from his home in
Hertfordshire it is Sir Rod Stewart uh
so Rod Stewart remind us why you called
in to speak to us at Sky News that day
on the day I spoke to you I just come
back from my scan in a private clinic in
Harley Street and I walked in I said I'm
terribly terribly sorry I'm half hour
late I said oh and that's okay we
haven't got anybody in here today
there's eight people there with the
hardly anything to do and then I thought
this is a terrible Injustice so here we
are so Rod is funding a mobile scanning
unit at princess Alexandra Hospital for
the day which means 20 people will have
their MRI scans and move off the NHS
wait list
when I see the hand he talked to me at
the door I mean that's him we know
that's the famous hand then come out and
it's him our staff Starstruck what have
I been paying the last 40 years for you
know I mean it's cost me money to get
this done he shouldn't be having to
subsidize it to get to get the actual
done mri's going done things came to a
halt in some ways in terms of elective
and planned Imaging activity over covid
so there's still quite a lot of uh
there's still a backlog of patients
we're trying to we're trying to get
through plus the new patients arriving
on the waiting list all the time on the
day Junior doctors decided to join NHS
industrial actions so Rod Stewart says
NHS staff deserve more there must be
enough money in the coffers to play up
for these nurses only two years ago we
were clapping and now
bless them they work so hard
so Rod Stewart with his own plan and
funding to help the NHS with the
government now follow suit but because
of your platform it created headlines
and you want to make some noise right
you want to make some noise about the
state of the NHS absolutely I do and you
know I just don't want to do it here if
this is a big success because I think it
will be a night to do in in Belfast
Dublin Edinburgh Glasgow Manchester and
just keep it going I hope some other
people followed me because I want to
prove I am not all mouth and trousers